the next question I want to leave here
I'm down here we go
[Music]
could be any question good one all right
I max who do you believe is the most
gorgeous queen of the season
a curious Chanel Davenport bacteria is
my grandmother's favorite my
grandmother's say that a kiria looks
like a woman act like the woman that
sound like a woman and that's why she
should win and then she later said
you're not far behind and as you can see
I'm the mother the next question I want
to leave here
how fabulous silky look tonight and yes
that's my question because you got to
leave it on to you baby
BAM so he was so good today so beautiful
she's I think it's a nod to her to her
insect gland that we saw on the main
stage I'm super super amazing how bright
are the lights of fame the lights of
theme are really bright but the real me
always shines through them what would be
your choice and lip-sync for your life
song if you could go back and lip-sync
to any song what song would it be
I would haven't probably do
living in America James Brown I
challenge anybody else to pick James
Brown what if you can replace anybody in
the top four who would it be and who
would you replace them with and you
can't choose this now that's too easy
girl I'll do it don't do it
I mean I would have to put my asian
sister plastic tiara if you can lip-sync
against any of the sisters from season
11 who would it be no I could pick any
like this I think so Joe let's send her
home
again easily yeah shame thank you what
is your biggest regret and on your
journey my biggest regret was packing
some a swimsuit
[Music]
not realizing all the designers we're
making me the same silhouette so that
was my biggest regret was not paying
attention to the details honey put the
camera off huh we gonna get my sister
shot I put it it okay that's enough back
to me the question god damn you gorgeous
and so nice your wedding can miss Benjy
be the flower girl to the wedding so
after that girl she could be the
minister give me the flowers or whatever
she wants to do but yeah
or anything if she could be at a video
game what video game will she be in
maybe pac-man because I love chase and
trade and I'm just like you know all the
little ghosts and like that's the best
[Music]
how tight is your tough oh honey it is
very very tight ain't nothing getting
through there actually no she's hanging
freaks there is no tuck tonight she is
comfortable if you could be a holiday my
holiday would you be Michele and what's
the question you want to leave for mo
name soap what up question mark talk
about a $2,000 [ __ ]